because essentially we have a society
where men are just paying for women's
bad decisions men pay the majority of
the taxes so who's paying for these
women to be single mothers then pay the
majority of alimony and child support
payments so again the men are paying for
the women to leave
um men build most of the inventions that
allowed women to go to work so the
Roomba the vacuum cleaner the washing
cleaner and invented it so women could
leave their home and leave little Timmy
at home and now we have we see the
byproduct of this where we have a more
free Society but guys our mental health
is crazy out here everybody's you know
got depression anxiety all this stuff
because women are raising the children
by themselves